[Music]
hey thank you thank you thank you
everybody oh thank you how's it going
guys I apologize that the video quality
isn't better I'm actually broadcasting
from Kansas right now which is where I
grew up I've been celebrating the fourth
with family but I wanted you to see
something an interactive youtube game i
made with annotations about a year ago
with Chris Brown and Rihanna if you
haven't already played the game I want
you guys to play it now because in just
a short while I'm gonna be making a
brand new interactive youtube game just
for Vsauce and it is going to be a
first-person shooter so be sure to
subscribe so you can be one of the first
people to play it what you're about to
see is gonna be a little bit backwards
you are actually gonna see what happens
when you lose the Chris Brown game Chris
Brown and Rihanna are gonna get married
forever but don't worry it's not too
late
you're gonna get two options that show
up one is gonna be to subscribe to
Vsauce which you should already have
done and the second option is to throw
more stuff at Chris Brown to save
Rihanna click that button wait for it
here comes oh no they're gonna get
married
ow
[Music]
you